hello everyone I'm here at Q con Seattle
and with me I have Dustin Kirkland
product product manager at Google cloud
kubernetes engine that's right
Dustin you have been with Google and
kubernetes for a while and we started
with you know Google cloud the
kubernetes engine has taken off in the
cloud since then what have we been
working on what's new and with Google
cloud I've been really excited to work
on bringing gke on Prem so Google's
kubernetes engine which we host a
software-as-a-service version of
kubernetes in google cloud back in
August of this year Google announced our
intention to bring gke on Prem and this
is like completely new for this is new
for Google yeah we've we've never really
taken Google technology and put it into
a data center at this kind of at this
kind of scale from the background that I
have I have been working with
enterprises and bringing Linux and
open-source into those enterprises and
so it's been fun and interesting to
share what I've learned over a 20-year
career doing that but here with Google
which has some incredible technology
that typically is hosted technology but
doing that on Prem in the enterprise
data center is a different challenge why
now why is Google going into on Prem if
it's this is not something Google's done
in the past yeah it's it's its response
to an incredible market opportunity
there's a ton of workloads that run much
better in the cloud and I think we've
seen the explosion of public clouds in
response to that but increasingly there
are workloads that cannot run in the
cloud workloads that have to run on Prem
and that is a little counterintuitive to
maybe some people who are all cloud
native 100% cloud native and so you know
you think about something like the
retail industry and the software that
needs to run inside of the inside of a
store right there are physical sensors
inside of the store that needs to have
software running against those sensors
now those sensors can feed data to the
cloud and where decisions can be made
but the actual code that reads the max
trip on a credit card or the NFC or the
chip on a credit card
that's code that has to run physically
within the goal of feet
of of the card reader the chip reader
the same goes for the sensors inside of
a restaurant inside of the inside of the
refrigerator of the store all that's
internet-connected nowadays and I think
over the next couple of years you'll see
the the in-store experience the
experience we have as a customer coming
into a brick-and-mortar traditional
retailer we're really going to see that
enhanced and enhanced by technology in
the store and across the board every
retailer that that I've met its
packaging their own applications either
applications they've written or
applications they purchase from a
third-party packaging those as
containers in deploying them to
thousands of stores multi-node clusters
and thousands of stores that sounds
awesome so what are some of the benefits
that folks are gonna get when they you
know have their clusters mounted by gk
on-prem folks being your system your IT
administrator retail you know companies
or whoever is going to be using gku on
from right right so from like in a
system administrator an IT standpoint i
think what you'll see is kubernetes
managed as appliances really appliances
in the store where below the layer of
your application all of thats managed as
as a service software as a service it's
remotely updated it's remotely scaled
remotely monitored remotely logged and
the application that sit on on top are
scaled are are deployed are run in a in
a very seamless manner that sounds
awesome so how when our customer is
actually going to get access to this
good question 2019 2019 is the year of
of retail really adopting incredible
software at scale and I think it'll
change our lives and in ways that we're
only just beginning to see that's
awesome and so moving forward with gke
going on prem all of these things is
Google gonna continue to invest in
open-source oh absolutely I mean I think
it's in our DNA I've certainly been
around the open-source industry as a
contributor and author of open-source
projects for decades that attracted me
in my journey to Google have been with
Google for almost a year now Google's
commitment to open-source is something
that I'm very proud of and
I think increases in fact over time well
what are the benefits of being open
source why continue that investment yeah
I think it's it standardizes on a common
platform you know there's certain
aspects of software that once
commoditized make for a better playing
field for for everyone you know the
differentiation on certain things that
just don't benefit the end user for
differentiation it really doesn't make
sense and having a common open-source
base for that that layer of the
infrastructure and that layer started
very low and is slowly crept up crept up
in a good way because I think we've
layered on better and better services
the further to the top of that stack you
go the more commercialized or productize
in some cases proprietary that that is I
think it's inevitable though that the
layers continue creeping upward I think
that's a good thing for us as
open-source technologists and for the in
the end users benefiting from the
technology what do you think about you
have different companies that are all
kind of contributing to open source
sometimes these companies are seen as
competitors to a certain extent but open
source is a place where they actually
collaborate what are your thoughts on
that it's it's the nature of the game in
fact you know I think some of the
athletes that I have the most respect
for are the ones who have personal
interpersonal relationships with one
another off the field you know on the
field it's it's gridiron it's it's a
battle but to shake hands at the end of
the game and say you know we were we
were best at this time and you know
we'll do better next time that sort of
collaboration I think you see an open
source as well we will compete we will
compete in in the market and from a
technology perspective but we'll also
collaborate around around the open
source and I think that's a sign of good
healthy companies and good healthy
business models and on the flip side I
think when you when you see
organizations that that can't
collaborate well that's the sign of
something you know unhealthy going on
perhaps in them in a business model
sense and looking forward into 2019 what
are the things that you're most excited
about GK on-prem of course but what else
yeah so I mean I'm gonna double down on
that one I think gke on Prem at
tremendous scale
in the enterprise data center for sure
that's that's where we're we're
currently engaged today so putting gke
on Prem into racks of servers in a
traditional data center the other place
is at the edge you know in this this
retail sense thousands of little data
centers thousands of five node data
centers right that is happening in 2019
and I'm I'm excited to be a part of that
that is very exciting yeah so let's talk
about cube con this is not your first
cube no no no I thought last one was in
my last one the US was in my hometown of
Austin Texas so it's it's it's
incredible to see it just double in size
from a year ago December a year ago
Copenhagen was incredible had a blast
there oh my god the food in Copenhagen
we we ate our we ate our way through the
Michelin Guide in in Copenhagen that was
a lot of fun but I also attended Berlin
a year and a half ago and boy that was a
small conference compared to compared to
this so it's grown up quite a bit what
are you looking forward to this week to
pun yeah I think really educating more
of the community what we're doing here
but also learning from the already
advanced users of kubernetes hearing
from them their use cases if they're a
customer they're there their pains if
they're a developer trying to write
applications for kubernetes as a product
manager it's incredible opportunity to
get feedback from our customers and the
community that's awesome and finally
what's your favorite cube con memory
cube con memory you know I got a I got a
hoodie a kubernetes hoodie yeah six
months ago I guess it was at the
Copenhagen cube con and I was wearing
that hoodie a week ago last week and I
took my car into the shop to have some
repairs done on it and in fact the
mechanic that took my car was wearing a
github hoodie and so I complimented her
on her hoodie and she told me hey nice
kubernetes hoodie yeah I like that and I
just thought what a what a what a cool
world we live in where someone who's
evidently writing some code and you know
using github on the side is also working
on
my car and you know in the same field of
endeavor we are with with kubernetes and
is wonderful as the beauty of open
source all right thank you so much for
your time you that's not gonna beat ya
good see here
[Music]